[Music]
meet orbit Manasseh born in Vienna he's
a passionate European who's credited
with writing the first novel in which
the EU plays the main role it's just
been named this year's winner of the
German book prize naturally I'm happy
about it I think every author wants
recognition for their work and its
efficacy and anyone who claims he
doesn't need it that it doesn't matter
to him his line of that out short his
book is entitled d-hop stud or the
capital and refers to Brussels the
control center of the European Union
Manasseh spent four years there
conducting research for his novel which
shows that Urich rats can make four
wonderful fictional characters in
literary terms how did you go about
transforming Brussels this you Rock
recei this abstract power structure into
a human story
this is concentra my the initial
approach is quite simple working it all
out isn't always so easy but starting is
you just have to assume that even though
it's an abstraction it's one made by
people and you can tell a story about
anything man-made that's why I went to
Brussels for a closer look to see it
concretely because it plays a role in
and has an impact on all our lives his
GU cosmos is man-made and hysterically
funny in the NASA's novel ambitious
civil servants decide to give the EU
Commission's battered image a makeover
it's a bold venture with wit and humor
Manasseh writes about political power
games narrow-minded nationalism and
about the need for peace in Europe
Zingo support you're a great
pro-european host nationalist as a
writer do you think a book like yours
can affect change do you know the fable
about the sparrow that lies on its back
with his legs in the air a cat comes
walking by ordinarily it would eat the
bird right away but it's intrigued by
the way the sparrows lying there and
asks an animal of the skies why are you
lying on the ground with your legs in
the air the sparrow says I'm afraid the
sky will fall down the cat says and you
think you can prevent that with your
thin little legs and the sparrow says
it's all I can do and you see I'm the
sparrow so there's at least a glimmer of
hope
horbet Manasseh captures the mood of the
EU at present with all its serious
undertones and his books attracting
attention worldwide publishing rights
for the Capitol have already been sold
in 35 countries
[Music]